Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conners with your 60-second cancer update.
Today, we're going to talk about a study that just came out of Finland, Switzerland,
area in Europe that showed the vulnerability of glioblastoma.
That's what they were studying, this study.
And the light, the light, uh, lysis oval membrane.
Your lysis oms are little organelles inside of your cells, all your cells have these.
And they, uh, house a bunch of digestive enzymes that were released, help break down and recycle
cellular components there, the cleanup of the cell.
Well, the thought was if we could get these lysis oms to break down and thereby spill all their contents
in the cell, they would effectively stimulate apoptosis and stimulate cell death.
Well, this study focused on that.
How could we weaken the lysis oval membrane?
So, uh, what they did is they found that antihistamines, and in this, in this, uh,
the case they use clavistite, which is an antihistamine that readily crosses the blood-brain barrier
because they were dealing with a brain cancer.
But they found that antihistamines would break down that like lysis oval barrier and spill its enzymes,
all the digestive enzymes that are in lysis oms would spill it into the cells and stimulate apoptosis
thereby causing the cell to go through death.
So, they found that they could help kill cancer cells, glioblastoma cells, which are one of the most aggressive brain cancers we have today,
by using a simple over-the-coder antihistamine.
And the theory is, is that we could use, uh, natural antihistamines as well.
So, using natural antihistamines and I have multiple videos and, uh, and a blog post on histamines and cancer,
not just with brain cancer, but breast cancer and other cancers that it's from proven that histamine is a stimulator
to cancer because it protects that lysis oval barrier.
So, by breaking down that barrier, we're affect spilling digestive enzymes into the cell and causing cell death.
And, helping at this interesting thing about the study is that healthy cells were protected.
It didn't have that same effect on the healthy cells.
Really cool. We'll read my blog about it.
It's another possible thing to add to our cancer protocol.